♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est la plus grande fête en
trois ans à Taïwan. Le premier
défilé de la fierté gaie avec
public en depuis le début
de la pandémie.
Ce n'est pas la pluie qui allait
arrêter les célébrations.
"Personne ne peut ignorer
la cause", dit cette fille
qui accompagne des amis gais.
Cette 20e édition célébre
les progrès réalisés. Taïwan
est fière d'être perçmemememe
un bastion de la diversité.
"Je peux être moi-même, dit-il.
Je me sens accepté aujourd'hui
et j'ai confiance en moi".
Il y a trois anïwan a été
le premier endroit en Asie
à légalismamamamariage entre
conjoints de même sexe.
(cris de joie)
Pour les visiteurs, la petite
île de 24 millions de personnes
se veut un modèle d'ouverture
et de tolérance.
Si les participants au défilé
célèbrent les réalisations des
dernières décennies à Taïwan,
il y a aussi un sentiment
de travail inachevé.
Les organismes de défense des
droits de la communauté LGBT
réclament entre autres le droit
à l'adoption pour les conjoints
de même sexe ainsi
que l'élargissement du droit
au mariage.
Pour le moment, seuls
les conjoints de même sexe
provenant de pays où le mariage
gai est légal peuvent se marier.
Les Taïwanais ayant
des conjoints japonais, coréens
ou thaïlandais n'ont donc pas
le droit.
Le travail d'éducation doit
aussi se poursuivre, selon elle,
il y a encore une partie de la
population qui refuse d'accepter
la communauté LGBT.
♪ ♪ ♪
Qu'ils soient militants
de longue date ou participants
pour la première fois,
lebrbrbrbrations de la diversité
ne font que commencer.
Des activités sont aussi
prévues dimanche.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,adadadadie